Alan Dershowitz is a well known attorney and
legal scholar. Historically a civil libertarian,
considered a man of the left for many years
by any reasonable assessment. He's a scholar
of constitutional law, a scholar of criminal
law. He's been involved in many high profile
cases. He teaches at Harvard and something
happened to Dershowitz over the last few years,
really around Donald Trump where he has to
become an unhinged defender of Donald Trump
and someone who has touted some very strange
legal theories and he jumped into the Russia
probe witch hunt nonsense. He's become a completely
untrustworthy guy on all counts and he is
now claiming that essentially, even if all
allegations against Trump are proven, Trump
still would not be impeachable check this
out. He's been making the rounds. He did it
on ABC's this week with George Stephanopoulos
yesterday where he said if everything Trump
is accused of is proven, Donald Trump still
cannot be impeached.
That there was a, your position that president
Trump should not be impeached. Even if all
the evidence and arguments laid out by the
house are accepted as fact. That's right.
Uh, when you have somebody who, for example,
is indicted for a crime, let's assume you
have a lot of evidence, but the grand jury
simply indicts for something that's not a
crime. And that's what happened here. You
have a lot of evidence. Disputed evidence
could go both ways, but the vote was to impeach
on abusive power, which is not within the
constitutional criteria for impeachment and
obstruction of Congress. Those are both the
kinds of things that led Hamilton and Madison
talk about nightmare to regard that as the
greatest nightmare. Number one, giving Congress
too much power, uh, to allow the president
to serve at the will of Congress. And number
two, as Hamilton put it, the greatest danger
is turning impeachment into a question of
who has the most votes in which house. And
rather than having a consensus and a broad,
broad view of impeachable con brief
can't impeach because he's not been impeached
for something that is a crime. Now hilariously,
check out what Alan Dershowitz was saying
back when it was bill Clinton's impeachment.
This is video from the infamous Larry King
live back in 1998 a program I grew up with
where Dershowitz says impeachment is serious.
You don't have to impeach over a crime if
someone has corrupted the office of the presidency.
What a different point of view back then,
so it certainly doesn't have to be a crime.
If you have somebody who completely corrupts
the office of president and who abuses trust
and who poses great danger to our Liberty,
you don't need a technical crime, but remember
that because the executive power is vested
in one person, the president, unlike the judicial
power which is vested in justices of the Supreme
court and inferior judges, will the legislative
power in a a hundred senators and 400 and
something representatives, we have one president.
And to impeach a president is like a nonviolent
revolution. It is the most dramatic act of
undoing democracy that is possible and that's
why the framers use the term a treason, bribery,
high crimes, and misdemeanors to suggest the
English analogy to great offenses of state.
We look at their acts of state. We look at
how they conduct the foreign policy. We look
at whether they tried to subvert the constitution
the way Iran Contra did. It certainly doesn't
have to be a crime. Donald Trump has now hired
Alan Dershowitz. He has also hired Kenneth
Starr, the special prosecutor who brought
an investigated impeachment against bill Clinton.
Consider how insane this is given that back
during the bill Clinton impeachment days,
Alan Dershowitz was on the opposite side of
Ken Starr and said, Ken star is a risk to
American Liberty and they are now working
together to defend Donald Trump against impeachment.
This is not a case of politics, strange bedfellows.
This is more than that. The one a consistent
thing I will say about Dershowitz is that
as a civil libertarian, he has held some version
of the position that special investigations,
like the one against Clinton and the one by
Robert Mueller against Trump are starting
to get to the edges of the power of investigators
to search around for crimes. He's been relatively
consistent in that overarching principle,
but on these other issues, the big picture
is Dershowitz has gone from being a liberal
Harvard professor to one of the most prominent
defenders, a priori of everything that Donald
Trump does or might do. There's a really interesting
article that I've previously recommended.
It's from 28 2018 it was written in political
magazine and it's called what happened to
Alan Dershowitz and it talks about all of
the judges and legal scholars who know Dershowitz
personally. They can't figure out what happened
to the guy.
It doesn't seem that it would be for money.
He's worth about 25 million bucks and it's
not really clear how profitable the Trump
Apple logia is. Anyway. It might be the idea
of being close to power. I don't know of another
president that, uh, Dershowitz has been this
close to and has had such a prominent relationship.
Maybe he likes the idea of that he's an 81
year old guy at this point. It's all very
strange. It's a very sad way to close out
a long legal career and we can expect more
of the same from Alan Dershowitz as the Senate
impeachment trial gets going. The plan as
of now I will say is to stream as much of
it as we can. I still have not found anything
definitive about whether Mitch McConnell is
going to force the coverage to be just like
one fixed camera really far away in the Senate
or whether they will actually allow Seaspan
to do a multi-camera production of the trial
the way that they do of Senate proceedings
in, in general. Uh, but my goal is tomorrow
1:00 PM Eastern time, Tuesday is the first
day of the trial. My goal is to be streaming
and we will see if we can make that happen.